foreign
there is quite a little stir going on
even among the Ramsay baby steppers
Community about these eye bonds we've
got a couple of days if you want to put
money into an eye bond and get 9.62
annual interest for series I bonds and
so because the rate has gotten so high
uh it's gotten everybody's attention not
everybody's attention but people are
buzzing about it
um and so people are saying Dave what
should we do what should we do what
should we do well
um let me tell you that what how much
money I have in I bonds and how much
money I will be putting in I bonds
precisely zero
hmm
why is that well 9.62 is the annualized
interest rate for the first six months
after six months it will drop to
whatever the prevailing rate is at that
time and that has traditionally been
down closer to five percent uh we're
thinking most people are thinking it's
gonna be about six and a half percent
beginning in November so you're pretty
sure it's going to drop at least to that
after six months and if you do not leave
your I Bond alone five years to cash it
out early
you get charged three months of the
interest that would be one-fourth of the
interest and so if you average six and a
half and nine and a half uh you would
get eight and three quarter something
like that or eight and a half roughly
um and
seven seven and some change anyway and
then take a fourth of that away
uh that's what you're gonna be making
and even less because it's going to
adjust down further later so the problem
is this it's giving you sh it's giving
you decent it's giving you way above
average short-term interest rates but
it's not really a short term interest
product
it punishes you if you don't leave it
alone long term and it's a lousy
long-term product because I can make a
lot more than 962 on average investing
in good mutual funds stock market is
average north of 11 percent I've been
investing in mutual funds for 40 years
and I've averaged Way north of 12
percent on my mutual funds over that
number of years way better than 9.6 oh
wait it's not really 9.6 it's only 9.6
for six months oh wait you can't get it
out earlier than five years unless you
get one fourth of the three months of
interest is a penalty and so people
don't read the small all they do is read
the big and the big print says woo 9.6
9.6 you get can't beat 9.6 9.6 is
amazing it's amazing and yeah it is
amazing that's a great interest rate I'm
sure if I could get 9.6 on a six month
CD
I would take it absolutely and I you
know I talk about moving some of my
emergency fund there maybe but that's
not the terms on this
the terms are five years or you have a
three-month penalty
the terms are it's not 9.6 for a year
it's 9.6 for six months on a one-year
Bond and you know what the last six
months are no you don't because they
don't tell you until later it could be
anything and I bonds have traditionally
hovered down in the five and sub five
range throughout their history this is
an anomaly that's jumped up and so well
I think if you can't you just can't lock
it in and so it's a myth right and it's
getting a bunch of hype in the news and
the headlines are saying that 9.6
percent and then at the very bottom of
the article it says in like a small
paragraph the downsides and it explains
that change in the lock and all of that
so it's important to not just get lost
in the height but we'll realize the CNBC
article we have laying in front of us
for instance is your last chance to
secure nine point six two percent annual
interest rate for series I bonds is
October 28th wait a minute
not true
it's not annual
it's calculated as annual but only for
six months
six months is not annual so I mean right
off the bat we've misled with the
headline but uh and so but it gives you
something to write about it's click bait
it causes people to jump on your little
site and read your little stuff so uh it
you're not stupid if you do this but
you're stupid if you do this thinking
you're gonna get 9.6 percent
for more than six months
minus three months if you cash it out
early so if you're using this for your
emergency fund you cash it out early
you're going to negate most of what's
there so I don't screw around with this
stuff it's a variable interest rate
product with long-term implications and
heavy fees for cashing out early so it's
not a good short-term product and it
doesn't make enough to be a long-term
product so I don't have any money in it
that's why I don't have any money I'm
not trashing it it's just you guys you
just got to read to learn to look at
these things a little more carefully and
once you realize all the the gotchas
then you go well it's just not as sexy
as it sounds yeah